okay
well today we are featuring another
wonderful
journal club edition of the
of this youtube channel and we are
featuring
uh dr is that how you say it colin
yeah uh who is a postdoctoral was a
postdoctoral fellow until
yesterday as i understand in the machine
learning department at carnegie mellon
university where he was a core member of
the cmu-based delphi research group
supervised by ryan tibasharni
davis sharmini rami
his research is currently devoted to
developing statistical models for
forecasting covet 19 in the u.s
i just talked with dr eric topol
yesterday at
salt at scripps research institute i'll
have more to say about that later but he
works in
all sorts of aspects of statistical
astrophysics including
extrasolar planets and large-scale
structure of the universe
and he received the umesh gaba scar
memorial award for the best phd
dissertation in statistics and data
science
at cmu which is a huge huge honor and
award
uh and in this coming academic year 21
22 he's going to join the institute
of astronomy in the department of pure
mathematics and mathematical statistics
at the university of cambridge russell
reserve
has researched at the interface of
astrophysics statistics and machine
learning
uh and so what i love to do is to have
people to kind of communicate both to my
students and to other graduate students
and post docs in the world
that there's more to the universe than
just studying
cosmology and in particular there are
new methods new tools and technologies
like machine learning
so forth that are coming online and
luckily fortunately for me and for you
reached out
online and we connected and i thought it
would be great to get a
overview from a really up-and-coming
stellar contributor to this magical new
world
of artificial intelligence machine
learning and data science so
with that i'm going to ask colin to take
it over and then at the end we'll take
questions so colin thank you so much for
joining uh our humble
cosmology journal club talks
yeah absolutely thank you so much for
having me i'm
really happy to be here and
especially excited this is very apt for
me to be giving this talk today
as my first official day back
focusing 100 percent of my research
efforts toward
applications to astrophysics and so i'm
really excited to
just uh give a rundown of the the
greatest hits
for my phd that i worked at this uh kind
of nexus field of
statistics machine learning and
astrophysics so i've titled this talk
three-dimensional cosmography of the
high redshift universe
using intergalactic absorption and that
is
the uh title of an upcoming paper
that was approved as a pre-submission
inquiry at nature
we'll be submitting in full as soon as
possible
now that i'm freed up again but i will
be discussing a lot of the other things
that i've done
but only very briefly and then and so
i'll discuss those
brief items first and then i'll get into
this topic
uh which involves three-dimensional
reconstructing
the large-scale structure of the
universe by using the lyman alpha forest
a very high redshift quasars
uh so that will be the focus of the talk
so i've kept that as the title here
um okay before i get into anything
really i want to
just plug this here that i've organized
this session at the joint statistical
meetings the flagship conference
the field of statistics this year it's
actually just coming up next week
and i organized this special session on
statistical challenges in cosmology
and so if you happen to be an asa member
or having to already
be signed up for jsm or just want to
register late and it is pretty expensive
admittedly i'm i'm
honestly currently battling them about
this
trying to get future uh
astro uh registration fees for
astrophysicists to be free
to be completely waived in the future
would love that
um we'll see if i can get them to budge
but anyway
this this current year i've organized
this session
in which i'll be speaking on the work
that i'm speaking about today
as well as several other
statistician cosmologists statisticians
um from icl max uh
autenreith and marcus rao also from
cmu's
postdoc at cmu and then yin li from the
flatiron
uh cca and so that should be a a lot of
fun then we have
jessie chazewski k was one of my phd
thesis advisors and she's one of the
leading experts in
the growing field of astro statistics
in astro informatics and then chad
shaffer
same goes for him and he's also at cmu
uh and this is not the only session
at the interface of astrophysics
statistics machine learning
uh this year uh a record total of seven
uh astro statistics sessions were
approved
uh so that's pretty exciting so
many reasons to consider attending next
week
uh so first i'll just give you a brief
overview of my phd thesis work
uh not in much detail at all just the
general topics that i worked
on some of the applications in
astrophysics
i worked on exoplanets specifically
modeling
base voltage transit light curves
with some higher order change point
detection methods
in order to be able to automatically
detect the onset
and the end of transit events as well as
the depth
and all of the statistical uncertainties
uh
eclipsing binary stars doing something
very similar there it's a very similar
astrophysical phenomenon so
the amount the statistical analysis is
pretty analogous
uh general spectroscopic denoising
analyses and so things
uh like for spectroscopic classification
and redshift estimation
uh being able to efficiently generate
spectral templates for all the various
object classes
um observationally from actual
observational data
using this particular denoiser that i'll
talk more about
here in a little bit um and then
denoising the observational spectra
so that you can use that denoised
spectrum
in order to non-parametrically i'll
explain that word in a sec
estimate various emission line
parameters
i won't get into any specifics about the
emission line parameters
non-parametric um my statistical
collaborators and i
are very very much invested in this idea
of approaching problems
non-parametrically
the kind of analog or the
synonym astrophysicists use
model independent as a sort of synonym
for nonparametric
and i've learned to kind of let that
slide
but it's not quite right it's not model
independent non-parametric is really
just
with us you're approaching the problem
with as few assumptions as possible
worked a little bit on supernovae light
curves
uh similar to the spectroscopic uh
template generation from observational
data light curve template generation
prop
from observational data and then
estimation of observational parameters
like the
maximum light light the time of the
maximum
and the decline rate some
data reduction and compression um
we could all use some compression and
these large these massive astronomical
surveys
uh that are collecting one-dimensional
data sets
and all of these first five that i've
mentioned
are detailed in uh these two papers that
we put out
at the beginning of last year and
monthly notices of laurel astronomical
society
these are them i will provide
links somewhere or brian can
post links in the the youtube
description
uh but just to very briefly describe
what each paper
is about the first one this is just
the very first introduction of this
statistical tool called trend filtering
into the astronomical literature it's a
state-of-the-art
statistical tool it's not something
that's been picked up
in astronomy yet so this was the
intention the motivation
for the work just to bring it to
astronomy
um so in the first paper i introduced
trend filtering
it's a ryan tip cerani 2014 and also
statistics paper into the astronomical
literature
ryan's was actually as brian mentioned
my postdoc supervisor at cmu
all of this just happened to precede
this
a lot of my works just happened to be
based on
a lot of his work and his work from his
own phd
and then we decided to do a postdoc
together
um so the punchline of the first paper
is that trend
filtering is superior to all classical
statistical methods for one-dimensional
denoising
denoising one-dimensional data sets when
the underlying
signal has varying degrees of smoothness
and so that's intentionally there are
many ways in which you can
uh formally define smoothness
and so this is intentionally vague that
i'm just saying varying degrees of
smoothness but you can
see this paper for some more
mathematical rigor
on what exactly we call
smoothness and so when i say classical
methods these are probably
these probably include pretty much
everything that you use
or have used for denoising
one-dimensional data sets they
can include splines they include
gaussian process regression
um moving averages kernels
local polynomial regression and many
many others
uh in the second trend filtering paper
this is mainly focused on
applications just a bunch of examples
um on all the potential applications
just to convey
the sheer ubiquity of trend filtering's
utility
to observational astronomy and so as i
mentioned earlier when i described my
thesis work
uh we go through some exo
exoplanet examples eclipsing binaries
some general spectroscopic denoising
supernovae and
data reduction and compression so just
to illustrate here
on the right what i'm showing you is the
various forms
that a trend filtering estimate can take
a trend filtering estimator is a
piecewise polynomial
with smoothness constraints enforced at
the knots
at all of the places where the piecewise
polynomials join
the piecewise polynomials can take any
order
and so at the top here i'm showing you
constant trend filtering piecewise
constant
and then at the bottom this rug these
is what we call it in statistics uh
these tick marks show you
uh where the adaptively chosen not
lie and so that's one of the nice
benefits of trend filtering is it
provides this sort of um
intuition as to where the there are
change points
in the signal that you're analyzing uh
linear trim filtering quadratic cubic uh
generally we just
advise if you think that the signal is
smooth then use quadratic there's really
not much of a difference between
quadratic
and cubic trend filtering
um so this is uh
potentially a little bit esoteric just
for a brief
summary slide uh but for those of you
that may happen
to know about these things that i've
laid out here
subset selection in high dimensional
linear regression
is an np hard problem when you have
when you're trying to estimate a signal
why
or when you when you're trying to
estimate the underlying signal
from observations noisy observations why
from a potentially very large group of
features
x and
subset selection strives to just find
the best subset um
of any size of that all of your all the
covariates that you have
in order to and then just fits a least
squares estimator
ridge regression does something a little
bit fancier it imposes
shrinkage on the coefficients uh so it
lets
all of the covariates be in the model
but it shrinks the squares of the
coefficients to make sure that you don't
over fit too much
and then the lasso is something that
all of you probably have heard of is a
very widely celebrated compromise
between these two areas
ridge aggression is very fast
computationally tractable
because it's strictly convex and
differentiable everywhere
so it has a closed form solution sub
selections np hard
computationally intractable uh the lasso
is strictly convex and so it can be
uh solved by various convex optimization
problems
and it actually selects many of these
beta j's uh are forced down to zero and
so it actually does feature selection
there's this duality between these
penalized linear models
and p splines what we call p splines
penalized
splines um again if this is all
new to you don't stress out over it too
much
but variable not regression slots lines
are probably something there's something
that most astrophysicists
most observational astronomers that i
know have employed
but they're also np hard but and so
you might think then how are they
actually being
put into practice the way that they're
generally put into practice
is that they're not searching over all
the possible sets of combinations
of uh where the knots could be
they're just heuristically looking at
the data and saying i'm gonna put a knot
here i'm gonna gonna put a knot there
and let's fit it by least squares
generally
not good statistical practice smoothing
splines
uh have a lot of analogs to ridge
regression
very very fast close form solution but
one of the biggest drawbacks is that
smoothing splines can only really
reproduce
uh signals that are have
uniform smoothness homogeneous levels of
smoothness is what we would call them
uh and so they have variations but the
variations tend
to fluctuate uh with a
uh kind of the same level of the second
derivative
trend filtering fills this gap here in
the statistical literature
uh the same way that the lasso does for
high dimensional linear regression
and so it's very very fast it's
strictly convex
and it does feature selection and in
this case the features are the actual
knots of the one-dimensional signal so
that's how you actually get it to
automatically tell you
where there should be knots
and it can be solved by various very
very fast convex optimization
algorithms so i'll just give you a quick
example here i'm not going to motivate
any of these because i just don't have
the time
but when i say that trend filtering can
estimate signals with varying degrees of
smoothness
here are some examples here's a quasar
redshift 2.4
you have the lyman alpha spectral line
here and then of course the lyman alpha
forest
lyman alpha force is a very very wiggly
function what we might say in
statistical terms
uh and then to the right of the lyman
alpha spectral line
there are obser there are absorption and
emission lines
uh but nothing is severe or abrupt
and so you don't see the same degree of
fluctuations as you do
blue word of the lyman alpha spectral
line i'll just skip over this
galaxy one now for time uh but you can
really see
the variation and the smoothness in the
this uh denois stellar spectrum
where you have these long kind of
intervals
of smoothness and then you have these
deep dips where there
are these uh absorption lines marked
with the blue
blue lines uh and then i'll
quickly give you i know this is a
cosmology group and so
here i am showing you an exoplanet
example but just very quickly i
i'm going to assume again for a sake of
time that most of you are familiar with
this
whole idea of exoplanet transits
um and so part of this
second trend filtering paper we proposed
this
novel uh estimator that gives you
these that will auto using that higher
order
change point detection uh property of
trend filtering
will automatically detect this onset
of transit transit event for you
and the end of it and so on top i'm
showing you the raw
time series uh and then this is the face
folded light curve
of kepler 10 uh
phase folded with with respect to
kepler-10c
and then a kind of fancier trend
filtering estimator we
we let it have one extra hyper parameter
uh for even more flexibility
and this is the best fit from the
relaxed trend filtering estimator
uh and so you can see as expected here
as as long as all the systematic
corrections have been done
correctly then you expect a perfectly
flat line right here when there's
no eclipse going on and then the same
over here
after the eclipse but you have this very
very
abrupt event once uh the exoplanet
begins to
eclipse its host star and then
uh you have the maximum depth down here
and then
the end of the transit event right here
and
of course a statistician at heart
uh have to provide all of the
statistical uncertainties
in these estimates and so giving you the
full
bootstrap distribution of the
uncertainties in these estimates
down here um
and yeah kind of the takeaway is that
this is a very fast alternative
approach that can potentially improve
upon
or at bare minimum act
in tandem with as a supplement to the
traditional
mandel and uh a gall analytic like curve
models
that have been used since the paper
came out i think in 2001 and
it's by far the most highly cited and
still used uh
models for for fitting these these
transit models
uh coincidentally enough casey mandel is
going to be
my postdoc supervisor at cambridge
uh okay so just jumping back here to the
overview of my
phd thesis work
so i very briefly touched on all of
these things that were in those two men
rash papers
but what the main subject of the focus
of this talk is going to be
mapping the intergalactic medium via the
lyman alpha forest
i'll talk a little bit about
non-parametric estimation of the
unabsorbed quasar continuum radiation
uh and then one dimensionally
reconstructing lyman alpha absorption
fields
um from there along the quasar along
each individual quasar observer line of
sight
but these two are really just kind of
stepping stones to this bigger problem
that we're interested in
3d reconstruction of lime and alpha
absorption fields
so that will be the main the main focus
the the main focus of the main focus
of the talk
okay now i'll jump over here to this
second set of slides
um i might speed up or skip at various
points just to make sure that
i don't uh go over time these are my
collaborators
formerly my phd advisors larry wasserman
jesse just ek
rupert croft i had a very
interdisciplinary phd
i was very fortunate to work with uh
these wonderful
brilliant people superstars in all their
own fields larry's and
statistics machine learning jesse is
very similar to me in that she
works almost exclusively on astro
statistics problems
and rupert's a cosmologist
okay so i've structured the rest of this
talk
into these three parts and so first i'll
start by discussing the lyman alpha
forest
probably move pretty quickly here
because
i'm certain that everybody tuning in
live
uh knows pretty much everything that
i'll say about
the background and the sloan digital sky
survey uh
but i decided to still keep it in for
the sake of
i'm sure there will be viewers on the
youtube channel that'll appreciate
a little bit of background on on these
topics and then right up front
i'll finish the introduction section
with a summary of the work
and the summary a high level summary of
the results
and then i'll talk about a little bit
about one-dimensional mapping the
intergalactic medium
as i said a necessary stepping stone to
this grander problem
of reconstructing three-dimensional
large-scale structure maps
via the lyman alpha forest and then
hopefully
given time i'll spend the majority of my
time in this third section here
okay so the sloan digital sky survey is
something that i'm sure
you're all very familiar with recently
completed approximately
20-year survey unprecedented
most prolific uh galaxy survey
to date and i'm showing you the
the three-dimensional kind of uh the
catalog of all the galaxies and quasars
that the sloan digital sky survey has
collected over these
20 years and so i want to point out
while we're in here close to earth at
these low redshifts
you can we this lone digital sky survey
has
observed enough of these galaxies that
you can actually see
the the large-scale structure and so
three structures in particular that all
allude to
uh the high density regions these kind
of nodes
uh i'll refer to as galaxy protoclusters
and darker regions
as cosmological voids and then kind of
the the web like the spider web-like
regions
as uh filaments
but as we zoom back out here
quasars are much more luminous than your
typical galaxy and so
consequently uh we can observe them
from at much much higher redshifts uh
but we still cannot uh
observe them in nearly the number
density
as galaxies at low redshifts
and so the question here
really is since we can
since we can't resolve large-scale
structure or at least
99 or more astrophysicists that i know
believe that there's no way to actually
detect
those three types of structure
large-scale structures that i mentioned
filaments protoclusters and voids just
simply by the clustering of the uh high
redshift quasars alone
the question is can we use the lyman
alpha data can we also use these quasars
uh lyman alpha forest data to
give us a more holistic picture of
the large scale structure at these high
red shifts
and when i say high red shows i mean red
shifts roughly
greater than two
um okay so another definition that's
trivial for
everybody tuning in live the
intergalactic medium is the highly
diffused gaseous medium that pervades
the volume of intergalactic space and
contains a majority of the
baryons in the universe so on the left
here as i just showed you
as collected by this lone digital sky
survey we have this point process of
galaxies
and then uh the rest of the matter in
the universe we have the baryons
in the intergalactic medium or the
circum galactic medium
then we also of course have the dark
matter this is a simulation a small
very small cubic similar simulation uh
run by renew chen and jeremiah ostriker
princeton
um again something trivial
absorption spectroscopy uh
briefly defining it as a set of
spectroscopic techniques that measure
the absorption of light as a function of
wavelength do it
to its interaction with the medium in
this case
our medium is the intergalactic medium
and so the way that we actually um
indirectly observe the intergalactic
medium is via the slime in alpha forest
which is um
i'll show you a picture here looking up
in the sky we have this very very faint
dot
apriori we don't know what it is we zoom
in and that's just a zoomed in version
here but when we gather a spectrum we
can look at that
any astronomer worth our salt will be
able to tell you that that's
that's a quasar and then lining up
absorption lines or doing something
fancier you can
infer that that's a quasar redshift 2.39
the alignment off the spectral line is
this very very high peak right here in
blue word to the left of the lyman alpha
spectral line we have the lyman alpha
force the series of absorptions
that occur over a series of wavelengths
because of the expansion of the universe
since
the constant redshifting uh and these
absorptions in particular are marking
the presence
of diffused intergalactic uh neutral
hydrogen gas
in in intergalactic space
um this is just a simulated spectrum i
think i've said everything i need to say
i don't need to spend any more time
there
and then we'll give a quick look at this
process happening in real time just
because i really love this video
uh so we have a high redshift quasar
here we have photons
leaving it going to the right here
toward earth
uh the intergalactic medium shown as
this kind of
it's a continuous medium but it's shown
as just kind of this
patchy cloudy medium here and we have
the
um continuum of the quasar so that the
the spectrum when the light first left
the quasar
there's all kinds of things going on
here but the main thing to pay attention
to
as i've said repeatedly is the lyman
alpha spectral line here
and so at lyman alpha as we're
passing through intergalactic space we
see these absorptions
as the photons traverse these
intergalactic clouds is a deprecated
term but that's what they look like here
uh so i'll just say clouds uh and the
denser
the the denser the cloud that you're
traveling to
the more severe absorption you get in
the lyme and alpha forest
so statistically
you might already be able to telegraph
that the
the problem here is going to be able is
going to be
to invert these absorptions along the
one-dimensional line of sight
into a what's called a lyman-alpha
absorption field which then in turn can
be used
to as a sort of proxy for the
hydrogen density and the intergalactic
medium
and because of gravitational tracing it
can be
used as a very good proxy of the total
matter density distribution
okay so the barian oscillation
spectroscopic survey was a sub-survey
operating with an
sdss and so again i'm just showing you a
two-dimensional cross-section
of the catalog of boss galaxies boss
quasars
that were observed um and our main focus
will be on these quasars at redshift 2
because they can actually be observed by
the
sdss ground-based spectrograph um
and what we're interested in
reconstructing is this
this intergalactic medium here this
higher redshift
younger time in our universe when
everything was much more diffuse
and hadn't yet
collapsed into galaxies as much
um and based on our statistical analysis
we found that
approximately 160 000
uh quasar spectra lyman alpha quasar
spectra
were usable for this full analysis and
the reconstruction of the
three-dimensional
map so here as promised is the high
just a very high level summary of the
work
um i'm showing you all the another
cross-section here
along the celestial equator uh of all
the lyman alpha
quasars within plus or minus like half a
half a degree uh and then the one
dimensional lines of sight
that give you uh neutral hydrogen
density information along
that line of sight but then everything
right around
1.95 or so
is washed out by earth's atmosphere and
so that's why everything stops
right there so the first step is to
infer
the relative density of the igm along
each of these one-dimensional quasar
sight lines
um so each of the 160 000
usable spectra provided by sdss
second step is to pool the site lines
together and reconstruct a full
three-dimensional large-scale structure
map
third step is to quantify be a
statistician
and quantify the total statistical
uncertainty in the full
three-dimensional map
and the fourth step uh at least for our
work
uh kind of our first order science that
we've done
is to identify use this not just this
point estimate
map what we call it the reconstruction
itself but also this uncertainty
quantification framework
to identify statistically significant
candidates
for structures like galaxy protoclusters
and cosmic voids
okay so now i'll give you a high level
summary of the results
uh the punch line here is that we've
created the largest volume large scale
structure map of the universe to date
um i'll give you kind of the logistics
here
first of all these pictures uh
i'm showing you again a two-dimensional
cross-section
earth-centric um of the
matter total matter distribution matter
density distribution
um of the relatively local universe as
mapped by uh sds
galaxies and then also this
three-dimensional map
uh using the linemen alpha forest that
we've made
um and then on the left here i'm showing
you just a cubic cut out
400 megaparsecs over little h
on a side and this comprises
this accounts for approximately 0.1
percent
of the total volume of the map uh
in total the map is 47 cubic gigaparsecs
over
little h cubed which corresponds to 154
cubic gigaparsecs when you assume
um h naught based on the
uh planck plank cmb data
as far as sky coverage it covers
approximately 25 percent of the sky
spans the redshift range 1.98 to 3.15
and using the uncertainty quantification
we've been able to pick out
um compiled these catalogs
of approximately 180 000
uh statistically high significance
candidates for galaxy protoclusters and
cosmological voids
via the very significant over densities
and under densities
in the in the map uh altogether this was
insanely computationally expensive at
least
from my perspective uh it took
it took pretty i've been working on i
worked on this for like all of my phd it
took a very long time
uh the main thing being that
it's very all of the computations are
insanely memory heavy
and so you really really the computing
has to be highly distributed
horizontally over very powerful machines
and so in total
uh the cost of this analysis was about 3
million
cpu hours which it does not sound
impressive to most astrophysicists but
these are
3 million fully distributed cpu hours
where each unit of time corresponds
to a machine running with about 200 gigs
of ram and so it is something that is
very non-trip certainly non-trivial
i'll show you one more quick snapshot of
the map here
to show you the sky coverage these are
basically represents the footprint that
sdss
targeted this big region in the northern
galactic cap
and then a region approximately one
third the size in the southern galactic
cap
so you have this little uh lens here
to show you to zoom in and kind of show
you uh
what's going on at a closer level and so
in red we have the
over densities the negative lyman alpha
flux contrast values
where the um
the intergalactic medium is denser than
the cosmological
cosmological average uh at those red
points
and then the blues are the under
densities where
uh the density is uh
less than the cosmological average
okay so uh this is the getting into the
second section now and i'm
just quickly checking time again uh i'll
finally formulate this as a statistical
problem and so when we observe a quasar
spectrum and
it's lime and alpha forest more
specifically
we can think of this you know your
noisy observations this f of lambda i
uh as being an
uh this underlying signal plus some
noisy component and then we can
factor this signal into a continuum
and then an absorption component that
which we call the transmitted flux or
the flux transmission
and then we can further factor the flux
transmission
into the average flux transmission over
the full
sky at every given redshift
and then this term over here the
the delta f we call delta fluctuations
uh will tell you the relative
fluctuations
about zero at each given redshifts and
so that gives you this
zero mean response variable that we want
to map
where negative values that have been
mapped are
inferred under densities and
i don't know negative values are
inferred over densities
i'm sorry i mix this up sometimes and
then positive values
are inferred uh under densities
okay uh and so in the trend filtering
papers that i alluded to before
this is just the formal definition of
lyman alpha flux contrast it's kind of
this
fractional uh flux transmission quantity
uh and in the trend filtering papers
that i alluded to before we proposed
this novel
estimator where f naught hat
here is the the trend filtering
denoised estimate of the lyman alpha
forest
and then m-hat is this product here and
i'll just kind of hand-wave that we we
showed that
it has very good properties it's a good
estimator
and it gives good coverage with the
uncertainty quantification
that we paired with it and then i'll
just refer you to the paper for
additional details
so i'm showing you a an example spectrum
here this is a simulated example
this is the basic idea and orange is the
trend filtering estimate
optimized based on some
statistical method that has been around
for a while
and works really well in this setting
and then this blue
curve here uh serves as our kind of
proxy estimate
of the quasar continuum it's obviously
not the quasar continuum because
we the quasar continuum would be up here
as kind of a smooth maximum
we find it much easier to instead
estimate
a smooth mean and so that's this product
here
continuum is c of z and then this is the
average flux transmission
which moves the continuum down into the
middle of
the forest and so you can estimate uh
this product directly instead of trying
to estimate
these two things uh separately
uh and then this defining
our estimator as as i showed over here
uh this is just the point estimate given
by
this quantity over here seems to track
very well
um trim filtering just being
again this uh sure on the 2014 paper and
then
our two papers from last year but
again being very statistical the
question
uh i don't know if i
what your general procedure is if i
should respond to
questions in the chat in real time
oh we don't really have a general
procedure it's up to you
okay uh what is the highest redshift in
your data sample
c2 to z um
the highest redshift quasars that will
provide
useful information in the mapped
interval
that we've chosen which is 1.98 to 3.15
uh the most distant quasars are
somewhere around
like four ridge of four
they provide foreground information
okay and so now there's of course in my
mind there's always this question
when estimating something of uncertainty
quantification now we have our point
estimate
now we want our confidence bands our
confidence envelope
around it standard errors whatever
whatever you
want to call it um so the procedure that
we proposed for getting these confidence
bands
for this lyman alpha forest estimator uh
is it's called a parametric bootstrap
parametric
because uh it's parametric in the
the air distribution and so the air
distribution
uh employed by sdss and
i'm usually a very skeptical
statistician but it's
it tracks pretty well assuming that
these errors are
normal with some
known estimates of the zero mean with
some
known estimates of the variance provided
by
taking multiple exposures of these
quasars
so we do this sort of resampling
procedure where we we fit the
first we we create a resampled lyman
alpha
uh forest which is basically just like
another
realization of the and alpha forest that
it could have been
based on the uncertainties that were
given
uh by sdss and then fit the trend
filtering estimate
to that um hypothetical
which we call bootstrap lyman alpha
forest
fit the mean flux level like we did
before that m
product quantity and then define the
flux contrast estimate in the same exact
way as this fractional
um transmitted flux quantity
and then we construct our variability
bands of
one minus alpha variability band in this
percentile
approach where you take the percentiles
of this
large quantity of bootstrap samples
that you've constructed through these
first three steps
so this is just the slide that i showed
you before with the point estimate that
we're happy with because it seems to
track very well
but we what we would like to know when
we see something like this
uh we don't get that orange but that
black dash curve that tells you the
ground truth instead we just have the
orange one
and so when you see a dip like this you
think okay there
it may be crossing over uh a filament
galaxy just some over density in the
large scale structure of the universe
but is it real and so that's what the
motivation for the uncertainty
quantification component of this these
are the 95 variability bands
for this particular example you see
something like this
this is 95 confidence right here
and so again referring to this dip you
have 95
confidence that it's somewhere down here
and so we can be
very very confident that at this red
shift along the place our observer line
of sight
this is almost surely an over density
okay finally getting to this uh last
part the the three-dimensional mapping
um i may start to get a little
quick here uh because i don't want to
take too long but
uh the the three-dimensional problem of
reconstructing
the lyman alpha absorption fields is
something that isn't new it's been
around for
approximately 20 years um but
it's something that hasn't been
at least in my view it hasn't been very
well developed certainly there hasn't
been the final word on it yet
there's been a lot of room for
improvement
there's also been a dire need for
improvement of computing resources in
order to make things like what we've
done in this particular work possible
um but across all of this lime and
outlet forest tomography work
the underlying goal the fundamental goal
is to reconstruct a full
three-dimensional large-scale structure
map from a dense collection
of one-dimensional maps one-dimensional
maps provided by
individual quasar lines of site so i'm
showing you some real
sdss data here of quasar lines of sight
a very unusual data design
as we would say statistically and so you
have
much denser lines of sight at low
redshifts and then not only
do you get much lower density at higher
redshifts simply because of the
spherical geometry
but also because of the faintness of the
quasars that these will just
these lines of sight fall off
drastically
and so i'm showing you the mean
transverse line of separation than being
uh it's comparable to the mean angular
separation
of these quasar lines of sight here on
the right and you see this
uh design heterogeneity and it's very
severe and so at low redshifts
uh we get these this much closer mean
transverse separation
and then it really starts to trail off
as you get to the higher redshifts
and so that's why we had to draw the
line
at some point in what we could feasibly
attempt to reconstruct a lyman alpha
absorption field because
after a certain point you're just going
to get nonsensical
noise that just fluctuate around zero
you're not going to be able to
resolve any coherent structure but
i'm adding a lot of additional
objectives essentials here
in my view in my years of working on
lemon alpha forest tomography
things that i kind of uh
argue should be part or
are essential to the problem of
alignment off of forest tomography
again this word of nonparametric making
as few assumptions as possible because
the structure of the universe is
incredibly complex
and we don't want to be forcing in any
prior assumptions that violate are
severely at odds with the actual
structure that's out there
and instead taking in that same vein
taking a very data driven approach and
so just
listening to what the data is telling
you in optimally reconstructing this
three-dimensional spatial field
so the idea is to optimize this
three-dimensional map to be
predictive of structure lying in between
the sight lines not just
to uh optimize it with some
in-sample metric that best recovers the
structure
along the 1d site lines that you've
hopefully already analyzed uh
independently with a one-dimensional
analysis
because if you're doing that then you
might as well just stick to the
one-dimensional analysis if you're
evaluating yourself
along those dense one-dimensional
sidelines the goal of three-dimensional
line and alpha force tomography
should be to fill in the gaps to fill in
the rest of the three-dimensional space
uh okay so multi-resolution the universe
has structure at various fields and
so so too should our spatial statistical
models
i could say more but again i'll leave it
at that
uncertainty quantification continue to
track all statistical uncertainties
uh that propagate into the reconstructed
three-dimensional map
computationally efficiency and
scalability
this is something that i've already
alluded to that's been a huge barrier
for a very long time to reconstruct
a three-dimensional map of this
magnitude spatial statistics
spatial modeling in general and
especially the higher dimension that's
that you get to is an incredibly
expensive
endeavor and uh again data of this size
volume of this size this is all very
computationally intensive and so even
though
we have more powerful super computers
now we still have to
make a lot of computational
considerations
so some extra you know somewhat clever
uh distributed computing approaches
enforcing sparsity as much as possible
in the matrices
in the linear systems that we're solving
in order to get
these reconstructions and the bootstrap
reconstructions
so that this can actually finish within
the duration of somebody's phd
like my own instead of just taking many
lifetimes
okay so uh i tried many different
um spatial models for this particular
project throughout my phd and you can
see my thesis if you're really
interested in all the ones that i tried
but i'll just tell you that this
multi-resolution spatial kernel ridge
regression
as we call it is the one that we
ultimately settled on
and it's defined concisely by this cost
functional here
so this cost functional uh balances
these two terms where you have a
weighted sum of squared errors
here where the delta f hats are your
one-dimensional maps that you've already
constructed via section two
v is your spatial regression matrix
multi-resolution
contains all these multi-resolution
compactly supported radial basis
functions
and then beta is uh your vector of
coefficients for those radial basis
functions
w is a weighting matrix that you know
does the typical
serves the typical purpose of down
weighting with respect to
inverse uncertainties um
but there's an extra little uh
ingredient
in there as far as down weighting with
respect to
the variation of small-scale structure
when i say small-scale structure i mean
structures that cannot feasibly be hoped
to be reconstructed in the lyman alpha
absorption field
based on the line of sight density that
we currently have
and so we add we put some extra effort
toward that to down weighting the stuff
that we simply we don't want to penalize
ourselves
with respect to the stuff that we simply
can't hope to map
on the right here we have this
penalization and so this goes back to
the bridge regression that i spoke
a while ago on this is a generalized
ridge regression so we're not just
uh penalizing these basis coefficients
independently
but we actually have some joint
penalization here that i'll talk more
about here in a little bit
uh that enforces the spatial smoothness
in particular
the multi-resolution spatial smoothness
of the reconstruction
so that uh neighboring basis functions
neighboring basis coefficients are
similar
and the field actually looks scientific
it looks
astrophysical cosmological
um once you've solved this problem
which i'm going to tell you how we did
in a minute but
given that you've solved this problem
and you've minimized
this cost functional over all the beta
coefficients
over a large number of radial basis
functions then you just simply take
these basis coefficients
and plug them into this multi-resolution
basis expansion and that's your
reconstructed massive 154
cubic mega gigaparsec
excuse me uh three-dimensional map
uh so i'm just briefly showing you the
radial basis functions that we used here
this is a one-dimensional analog
of these uh windland polynomials
uh three level bases here i'm showing
you a two-dimensional example here
how they're organized they're organized
on regular grids of
dyadically increasing resolution
then the contours that i'm showing
showing you correspond to this d
matrix here the spatial smoothness
that's imposed
so there's a spatial smoothness that's
imposed at each level of resolution
in this spatial reconstruction
and so it tells the reconstruction how
how smooth that component of the
estimator
should be at that level of uh at that
scale
oh hey colin sorry to jump in here i
actually personally need to leave for a
meeting in a few minutes
um if other people can stay on i
i would love to see the rest i think
this is actually a fantastic talk and
i'd love to see the rest of the
recording i just want to check with the
other
people online if that's fine do you know
about how much longer your talk
will be uh it should not be
too much longer i the
what's left of the slides are ones that
i can breeze through
at a relatively quick pace okay cool
yeah sorry i might have to drop out a
few minutes i do have a question i'll
put it in the chat though if you don't
mind answering at the end
yeah of course okay thanks
okay so getting back to this uh this
cost functional here
somewhat mysterious that i've just kind
of described at a high level
uh i give you some of the more details
here that perhaps
would probably be more of interest to
the more statistical
uh people but it's you know block
diagonal treating each of these
levels of resolution optimizing them
independently
with a huge set of hyperparameters to
in our non-parametric you know
fashion uh make it as flexible
as possible to uh
adapt to the data and map the the
complex structure of the intergalactic
medium
um this first order fusion penalty is
just what
uh imposes the the spatial smoothness
that makes sure
that the reconstructed field is
relatively smooth
and then yeah this whole slew of hyper
parameters which
is honestly much less scary than it
appears when i just throw it down here
uh but i'm gonna i could describe it
term by term uh but
i'm gonna skip over that for now okay so
we we have this cost functional again
that
as i mentioned with ridge regression is
strictly convex differentiable
everywhere
so there's a closed form solution you
just take the derivative
you know typical calc 1 first derivative
test
uh close form solution
is there does that mean that it's easy
are we done
absolutely not so this problem in
particular
n by p uh they're the terms that we use
the variables that we use in statistics
the parameters in order
n is the sample size p is the number of
variables
and the regression that you're running
in this particular case the sample size
is around 72 million
and in this case p the number of
features being the radial basis
functions
are in order to map the uh
intergalactic medium at the resolution
uh
around the resolution of the mean
transverse sight line separation
you need 40 to 50 million radial basis
functions so this is a truly massive
problem
very very computationally intense
so i had to create this distributed
approximation the idea of the
distributed
approximation is to exploit
this um this kind of this very local
nature
of that smoothness kernel that is
imposed
in the penalty term this d here uh
just an artifact of the ridge regression
that it never actually goes to zero
but it goes very very close and so
that's why it's a just
distributed approximation not a
distributed solution
uh but close enough that it works
and it looks you know for our purposes
it looks great and so we construct a
local
uh multi-resolution spatial kernel ridge
regression estimator
the thing's a mouthful i really need an
acronym for it
um and then plug those local basis
coefficients into their own
multi-resolution basis expansion that
gives you this
uh local map here and then
we piece together this distributed map
in a piecewise fashion
and that gives you the full 154 cubic
giga percent
map
um model validation as i mentioned
there are a very large set of hyper
parameters that need to be optimized
and based on my background its model
validation is something
not all people consider but i
have to because i my training is in
statistics and machine learning and so
i'm very very
adamant about model validation and so
the way that we do this is we construct
an 85
15 train validation split not just a
random split but a split
on the set of background quasars why
because this is uh this is motivated by
our desire to optimize the
three-dimensional map to be predictive
of three-dimensional structure lying in
between the quasar lines of sight that
you actually train on
and so they actually can predict unseen
structure
in between the quasar lines of sight
uh estimating this third step here is uh
estimate the large-scale density field
along each quasar line of sight in the
validation set
and so you want to compare your
three-dimensional reconstruction
to something that's actually reasonable
to compare it to make it an apples to
apples comparison
and so by this i just really mean
that you take the one-dimensional map
that you made previously
which is relatively high resolution
along the line of sight
and you degrade it to the resolution
that
the best resolution that you can hope to
expect uh
to map in three dimensions and then you
choose a loss function
and we choose the kindle tau loss
function here uh
i really enjoy this part but
unfortunately i'm gonna skip over it
uh and then you take the minimizer of
this kindle tau
ranking distance and that's your
optimized set
of uh your optimized vector of hyper
parameters
but and so the the multi-resolution
kernel ridge regression is something
that
inherently naturally adapts
is what we call design adaptive and so
it'll be relatively smooth when data
are relatively sparse and it'll be
relatively
high resolution reconstruction when uh
you have much more dense data
uh that said this spatial this design
heterogeneity that i showed you before
as a function of redshift
is quite severe and so we give it this
extra boost
of spatial adaptive adaptivity by
independently optimizing
the the set of the vector of
hyperparameters
in each of these redshift bins
so all together here is our closed form
solution for our three-dimensional
reconstruction
split over three redshift bins and then
everything pieced together in a
piecewise fashion
it's the full map this is what i already
showed you on my wide projection
i think this is redshift 2.1 just a
slice of the three-dimensional map
again red being over density blue blue
being under density
uh and then just to show you some
various redshifts this is the same cut
out of the sky i think it's
uh i remember correctly 20 degrees by 20
degrees
and so as i said when data are
more densely available then we can
reconstruct the intergalactic
medium at higher resolution when they're
more sparse
then it's going to be a coarser
resolution and these six plots
show just exactly that at these lower
redshifts
in the top row in particular relatively
high resolution reconstruction
as you get to higher redshifts
particularly you'd see it at redshift3
we get a much much coarser resolution as
expected
okay so uncertainty quantification these
first three steps are things that i've
already showed you
uh in the one-dimensional analysis and
so again we do
each of those first three steps for
each of the individual approximately 160
000 quasar sight lines
and so what we're doing is actually
propagating forward
pushing through to make sure that we
account for all the statistical
uncertainties in this full
three-dimensional
reconstruction pipeline
so those are the first three steps and
then the final step in the set in this
three-dimensional setting
is to compute the the full distributed
three-dimensional model
again um from the pooled set of
bootstrap
uh sidelines
so we are genuinely producing a
bootstrap
reconstruction of the full 154 cubic
cubic gigaparsec map for each of these
bootstrap samples
again super super expensive and
wanted to finish the phd in a timely
fashion and so
uh usually i would like to do more than
50 bootstrap reconstructions
but i did 50 in this case for a sake of
time
something really really interesting
generally never really expect the true
uncertainty distribution
of an estimator to be gaussian in
practice
but this one is very very close
to gaussian and i have various
intuitions that i could share
on why but this was a very very happy
surprise because what that allows us to
do
we have all this data so much data uh
and it allows us to just record these
standard errors of this bootstrap
distribution and then use normal
quantiles
in order to produce the uh uncertainty
bands
okay so as i refer to our first level
kind of
science that we do with this is to
create these catalogs
um of overdense
highly significant over densities and
under densities to catalog
as candidates for galaxy protoclusters
and cosmological voids and so what we do
is we look at the level sets
of the reconstructed map and consider
the connected components that are at
least in standard errors
away from zero and so in standard errors
below zero or in standard errors above
zero
those give you the the over densities
the under densities
so not only do we get this
three-dimensional reconstruction
but we actually get these highly
significantly statistically significant
components these objects these clusters
that are likely to be there and we can
actually infer
with significant confidence
that this isn't under density in the
universe and this is an over density in
the universe
okay and i'm showing you just a broader
picture of these over densities and
under densities and
orthographic projection of the northern
galactic cap on the left
southern galactic cap on the right at
redshift 2.5
and so you can really kind of start to
get an idea again this is just two
dimensions of a three-dimensional map
but it can still nonetheless start to
give you an idea
of how many uh potential objects
novel objects out there that we've
compiled into this catalog that have not
been accessible
by any other means other than this
massive lyman alpha forest mapping
approach that we've taken
here i'm just giving you the numbers a
census of
the the different of all the objects
that we've
we've compiled the galaxy protoclusters
at a
three sigma significance level
these are the numbers all the way up to
uh eight sigma significance still
approximately
uh twenty thousand uh galaxy
protoclusters and cosmological
voids uh significant at that that level
okay so i think this is my final slide
and this is just really about
you know open source science so all of
this
everything is going to be available
either at this webpage
or on my own personal domain powered by
the pittsburgh supercomputer
huge thanks to them they've done a lot
of heavy lifting and getting this
massive sql database
up which is approximately 30 terabytes
of data
and it'll be queryable very quickly
because it's indexed
uh at a one cubic megaparsec resolution
over a little hq and then downloadable
he'll pick sky maps
uh for every 0.01 increment in redshift
space
uh between the limits of the
three-dimensional map
um and i believe actually this third
bullet point
all these skill picks maps are actually
already available at this uh domain
um and here's relevant references for
in particular for papers from my phd
this this first one here is the one that
now that you know i'm free of my
covid research i will be working very
hard to
get this published uh and get this out
there
as soon as possible uh the trend
filtering maps
and then an extra one on lyman alpha
forest
mapping and then various related ones
and thank you again so much such a
pleasure to be here
um always enjoy talking about
this work and always enjoy getting the
feedback of astrophysical audiences
so i'm more than happy to take questions
now
uh looks like there are a few in the
chat
let me maybe i might need a share screen
again based on the questions
um our cpus with 200 gigabytes
i think that's what you said required
for this analysis
or could you have run it on cpus with
less memory and just loaded
fewer quasar spectra at a time um
so all of the all
of the analyses are done locally
uh and so it
there's a trade-off there between how
big of a sub-map
you actually reconstruct
and how much memory you need to
reconstruct it
and something that i didn't mention is
that we also have to add
margins to all of our sub maps that we
piecewise
that we piece together in a piecewise
fashion in order
for the map to actually the aggregate
map to actually fit together in a
seamless fashion and so i personally
found it somewhat heuristically to be
most effective
to attack it the way that i did
um but just just to illustrate uh
i i was doing all of these sub maps
mostly at a they were based on the
number of basis functions because that's
the
the key com the key number that dictates
the
computational complexity um
but roughly speaking astrophysically
the cubes i was mapping them in cubes
uh were about 400 megaparsecs on a side
and so you can imagine if i instead
decided to
break it up into cubes of 25 megaparsecs
on the side
i still needed like uh
at least a 150 200
megaparsec buffer in every cartesian
direction
in order for that piece that
aggregate map to finally fit together at
the end of the day
and so that still would be really
expensive because of all those buffer
region
basis functions uh so it's a trade-off
um did the 85 50
15 split give the best effect have you
tried other combinations
uh this is just kind of based on
statistical lore
uh ideally i
would prefer to do uh something like
five-fold or ten-fold
cross-validation and so to actually
iterate through all the folds that you
break up the quasars into
and train and then test on a fold and
then train and test on another fold
and iterate you know five to ten times
uh which you know is the norm but again
with computational complexity uh this
was something that we just had to
you know bite the bullet and be okay
with
a data split just simply a data split
where you you split
once 85 train on 85
test on or i should say validate on 15
um and optimize the hyper parameters
that way
as far as does that particular uh
8515 give the best effect that's what i
that's what i mean when i say it's based
on statistical lore
because uh well not really lore it's
been shown
it's been shown that fivefold and
tenfold cross validation
have the best trade-off between bias and
variance
in the estimation of air
so 85 to 15
is right in between five-fold and
ten-fold
so that was the thinking there uh can
you and have you
applied this method to other spectral
lines eg carbon
mg2 etc no
um those are certainly things
that come into play uh
as we know uh but they're
pretty uh their effect is much much much
less than that of lyman alpha
and in fact if i were to incorporate
an other another spectral line
i think my first attempt would probably
be
lyman beta uh would
be to try to actually make use of lyman
beta because there's so much information
there
the struggle with that is that it's
quickly overwritten by lyman alpha
redshifting
over lyman beta um but
as far as like metals and stuff like
that
and other elements those are actually
the things that we
strive to avoid in our spectra and so
when i say usable spectra like 160 000
usable spectra
we throw out we've thrown out all the
spectra that
sdss has flagged as
likely to contain you know be affected
by
metal absorption because we don't want
something like the presence of metals to
cause a highly statistically significant
as a highly statistically sig
significant
over density in neutral hydrogen
all right thanks for the answers that um
does anyone have any other questions
you got a small audience here at ucsd um
no other questions and uh fantastic uh
talk thank you
uh nothing else i think that that's all
for uh this
uh fantastic journal club thank you so
much
so happy to be here sorry time
no worries very interesting hopefully
brian can make it work maybe
brian feel free to condense as much as
you
like you know whatever
[Music]
yeah all right yes but thank you so much
and thank you so much brian
and looking forward to uh being in touch
again at some
all point much appreciated cheers